From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Good.
Okay.
Today is Wednesday June 1, 2011.
My name is Joe Mosnier of the Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm with filmmaker and biographer John Bishop. We are in Montgomery, Alabama to do an oral history interview
for the series for the project entitled The Civil Rights History Project, which is a joint undertaking of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today we're in Montgomery to visit with Dr. Gwendolyn M. Patton. Dr. Patton, thank you so much for the welcome and it's a pleasure to be here.
Thank you.
I thought I'd start today.
Before we turn down, we talked about the fact that there are places here in your longer story where we want to be sure we place some extra emphasis.
Let me pick up today with this question for us to begin.
Can you paint the picture of Tuskegee in the fall of 61 when you arrived to start your years at Tuskegee?
Well, it was impressive. It was a large campus in terms of acreage.
The buildings were very, to some extent, ornate.
The main street leading up to the university, which we called Campus Avenue, intrigued me because there were no front entrances to the buildings on the main thoroughfare.
So I was intrigued by that.
And then of course, when we went through the Lincoln Gate, I knew that was named after Abraham Lincoln.
The National Guard greeted us.
And that somewhat didn't frighten me, but it bothered me.
And they were very courteous, but courteous.
And living with my grandmother, my called mommy, on my mother's side, I knew how to be stoic and not to be too expressive.
And I took cues from her and we went right onto the campus.
Later I learned that the National Guard had been called up because they were integrating the schools in the city.
And they were to be there for protection, which kind of baffled me because they were state troopers.
And they had never been friendly or kind.
And I had some understanding how the state could be trumped, if you will, by the federal, by the national.
And so they were not under the auspices of I think Governor John Patterson at the time, but rather under President Kennedy at the time.
So I learned that and I worked through that.
And the buildings with no doors on the main thoroughfare, which you would assume, I later learned,
that Book of T. Washington, even though I have to make clear that Adams found it the school, but Book of T. Washington developed the school.
And though he was called an uncle Tom, especially by the black intelligence here, with his the five fingers of the hand and all of that, the Atlanta exposition and an argument with W.E.B. Du Bois,
that I learned that indeed he was a race man. And he built the doors front doors, entrances, facing the campus.
And because the thoroughfare was used by white and black people, and he didn't want them to feel like they were welcomed.
And so all of the doors, if you go there even to this day, they're faced inward to the campus.
So that kind of pleased me, I like that. And then I learned a lot more about Tuskegee's history from subsequent presidents, much later in life.
But when I broke my leg in the car, I didn't break it, but this mysterious car accident in 1967, I had learned a lot about Tuskegee, its history.
I knew some before I went there, because when I was 12 years old or 11, I wrote my paper on George Washington Carver, and tried to dispel the myth of the peanut man, you know, that kind of reduced him.
And I saw him as a scientist, and I learned about Yams (sweet potatoes) and peanuts, because he also did stuff with Yams (sweet potatoes) and peanuts, and I learned about paints, and I also understood he had contracts with the paint people, and I learned about Ford, Henry Ford.
I think my daddy told me that my father, Clarence Robert Patton Sr, was a race man. In fact, I come from a race family on both sides.
So I was rather astute in the history of black people, even as a child. And so in 1967, with all of that thinking, all of what I knew about Tuskegee, Robert Russa Moton, who was the president of Tuskegee, after Washington, and they were building the VA hospital,
mainly for World War I veterans. I mean, not mainly, but for black, World War I veterans, there was this dispute, as to who would be the doctors, and the nurses, the professional staff, and the authorities to be coming from Washington, we have to understand Woodrow Wilson.
He said that the professional staff will be white people, and the help, the maintenance, and the nurses' aids, and the bedpan deliverers, and removers, and all of that, will be black people.
Well, Robert Russa Moton, who was president, said, no, we have black doctors. In fact, Tuskegee had a nursing program for RNs, or to become RNs, and there was Meharry Medical College, which produced black doctors.
And he said, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, we're going to have black professional staff, and living within the confines of Jim Crow, he was kind of on target.
And the white powers to be, because they saw money, they saw jobs, said, that's not going to be. So it became a big struggle. We're talking about in the 1920s now,
1910s, 18s, you know, teens, and they said that if a black person, professional, crossed those doors at the VA hospital, the clan will be there to do X, Y, and Z, which was violence.
And Dr. Moton said, okay, so he called out all of the World War I black veterans. This is lower, because I was not there, and nor were my parents.
And the story is that they lined the highway to the VA hospital, the black veterans, and the clan never showed up.
It's a proud history, there's no question of Tuskegee.
Yeah, and so to bring that full circle in 1967, when I was in this mysterious car accident in shorter Alabama,
and I was by myself in John Andrew Memorial Hospital, which was on the campus, and coming through some recovery, and that's a whole nother story.
I wrote a piece called Book of Teawashintern in retrospect, the father of black power, which validated why I wanted to go to Tuskegee,
in the first place. And what people don't know is that the Tuskegee Black Power Conference, and not in New Jersey.
And so Tuskegee was part of my deepening, my understanding of race pride and race progress.
The conference you've just mentioned is the one in 1967 organized by Sharp?
Yeah.
In Jersey? No, the one on the campus.
On campus it was organized by SNCC, and I under-wrote it. You talk about the Southern Human Relations Project, which was, and we call it, Sharp.
We under-wrote it. You have to understand my role as a sharp organizer.
We'll come to that.
Okay.
But it was really led by SNCC.
We'll come to that in some detail. That's great. We'll talk that through.
Your initial, obviously, we won't stop to do a lot of the personal history that brings you that point, but by 61, you obviously, as you say, are kind of a race person.
You're very attentive and conscious about these things. Your family's been quite assertively attentive in many different ways.
All of my life.
That's exactly what I'm talking about.
But you're also a student starting college, and you do things like cheerleading and going to class and theater or these things.
Is there much that distinguishes that period between your arrival on the campus and your departure to the sanitary when you have to go for the TV period to work your losses?
Is there much in that early period on the campus where you're closely connected to civil rights or not?
Yes, because I had to communicate back to Montgomery.
And you had the Freedom Riders that come through.
That's when I learned some additional things about my family.
This is the prior spring.
May, 1960, what I call it, the Mother's Day Massacre.
And the following day, which was a school day, if I may.
Well, I was at the mass meeting that they held all night.
Let's back up just once, so what happens is the Freedom Riders come into town.
Right.
And there's just all kinds of activity.
The Montgomery movement infrastructure jumped into our gear.
He's a great re who was a secretary to Dr. King and the Montgomery Improvement Association.
And dear mentor of mine, along with some other ladies, Mrs. Odessa, Williams later became ready.
They all jumped into gear to rescue and provide refuge for the Freedom Riders.
Telephones were above us with they beating us too out of them.
You know, do something, but not in the household where I was with my aunt chick and my aunt Flora, who were two school teachers.
My grandmother, mommy, eccentric did not have a telephone.
Okay.
And I could do it.
But my aunt Mary, who lived next door to my aunt chick, who had lived in Pittsburgh, was a little bit more broad-minded.
And so she was a part of the movement in somewhat of a real sense, though my aunt chick and aunt Flora were as well, in lending their cars.
But they were school teachers and, you know, the reprisals, as well as, they were kind of status conscious.
If you understand what I'm saying, they were school teachers, quote unquote.
Aunt Mary was a synchronous, also a school teacher, but had made a living basically as a synchronous and a tailoress.
And her husband was self-employed, you know, as a house painter.
So Aunt Mary comes to tell me about what's happening downtown at the Greyhound bus station.
And I want to go to the mass meeting.
I knew Aunt Chick was not going to take me because I was a child of the entire family.
I went to Aunt Mary's house, called my grandparents, the patents, who were very much involved, and they were independent workers at the Greyhound business.
They came and got me.
And so I went to that and said, I don't know that.
I have to ask you to say a little more because you stay all night because of very complicated, difficult situation.
Can you explain that at the mass meeting?
Well, as a child, I'm 17.
I knew there was terror outside the clubsters, as we called them.
We didn't call them KKK. We called them clubsters, my family called them the clubsters.
But as a teenager, like other teenagers in that mass meeting, we felt invincible.
And the adults, most of whom knew that God was going to protect us.
And see, that had been introduced and then reinforced during the Montgomery bus boycott.
We knew there was divine intervention.
So basically there was no fear.
Now we saw all these white men walking up and down and down and up.
You know, inside, I had no idea.
They were police or detectors or whatever.
I thought there were newspaper people.
And so that was that.
And then a youngster, young and then I, Jolacy,
was summing downstairs in the basement.
And you have to see first, this is a beautiful church.
And I later learned, I didn't know that night, that he was instructed to crawl through the basement window,
to go to his grandmother's home, which was not far, to make telephone calls for those who had telephones,
to let people know we were okay.
And he had to crawl under the houses.
And at that time, we didn't have encasement around houses.
The houses were built on what I call sticks.
And then later on they put a looming them around them, and then later on they break them.
And so forth. And later on they tore them down.
So that I do recall.
He was about 14, youngster.
I was 17, a senior in the old 90s.
I recall that.
But we're just saying songs.
And you know.
I think that day, earlier that day, some of the Freedom Riders have come to one of your relatives home.
My aunt Chick's home.
And an integrated group of writers.
Right.
And I'm interested in having you account the reaction of your...
Oh my goodness.
So I had them over.
I was curious.
I'd been up all night with them, you know.
And see there were lots of them.
So this is the day following, the day following.
And some of them stayed out at Reb and Solomon's Saves home, out in Madison Park.
And that's another story.
It's an old black community.
So anyway, teenagers all over the city, I don't want to make it seem like it was just me,
that sections of Freedom Riders came to each other's homes.
And my home was selected where I lived.
And I was staying with my aunt Chick and Flora, who were school teachers.
And I was enjoying them talking about the freedom movement and all of that.
And when aunt Chick came home, Flora taught in Lowndes County, which is the country.
So she came home much later along with a drive.
And aunt Chick was very smart in her dress.
You know, you know, and she wore these spike high heels.
And she had a clickety-clack when she walked.
I mean, poise and all of that business.
And when she came home and walked through the living room and saw these black and white kids
or young adults sitting on our sofa, I did not notice that she was disconcerted.
She didn't just display that.
And because of whatever affectations, and maybe I even have some of that as being a product of that,
she says, Gwendolyn come with me and I go to the kitchen.
And I knew she was going to get cookies and lemonade.
I mean, that's the nice thing to do.
We call them repass.
And as we prepare the tray, aunt Chick said to me in a very...
...and monitoring tone.
I don't want any white people in my house.
Now, I'm a race person.
And I see many white people in my life, my entire life.
But I saw something a little different about.
It was only one white boy.
And I saw something different about him.
And I said, oh, aunt Chick, I say, I might have used...
They're different kinds of white people.
They're not like the clubsters.
You know, I have this discussion.
And she made it very clear.
As long as I have to go through the back door of white folks houses,
they're not to enter the front door of my home.
And we always made a distinction between houses and home.
And I had to take that under consideration.
And then we... she clicked like...
...and I'm following behind her, took the lemonade and the cookies...
...out to the group.
And we ate and they stayed a little while and then they soon left.
Let me ask you about your experience in the sanitarium in Lafayette, Alabama.
Lafayette, Alabama.
Lafayette, Alabama, excuse me.
Lafayette, Alabama, Alabama.
You entered the sanitarium because to break losses in...
Was it early 60s?
63 January.
And we're there until March of 64.
So a year and a couple of months.
And I know that having read some of the things you've written...
...that were that experience.
It was difficult, including reasons obviously related to race.
Can you describe the essence of your experience in those months?
Well, I love the impatience.
It was a segregated facility.
You had to enter. I did.
The back door.
Up some steps.
I can still remember at age 68...
...the... the...
...bannisters or whatever you call them, rickety.
I was extremely weak.
I came up in an ambulance from Tuskegee, John Andrew Memorial Hospital.
I knew about the tuberculosis.
It was a plague.
And then being in the...
...at John Andrews...
...in the isolation unit.
I had oxygen at that time.
I had a tin.
You never looked at it.
And everybody was in white.
All covered up, masked, head, dough.
So I knew this was something very drastic.
Because I really didn't know about TB and consumption.
I knew about cancer, which was called a dreaded big C.
But I did not really know about burgloses.
I didn't even know it affected the lungs.
So I'm already traumatized by this disease.
So when I get up to Lafayette, Alabama, I mean Lafayette, Alabama.
And it's Benson, I believe it is, I have the correct name, sanatorium.
The front of the building is very impressive.
I have a photo of the building here in my archives at home.
Very impressive.
Now, mind you, I have not been around white people.
And those few I was around were not authority figures.
So we ride on around, go through the back, gravel and red dirt.
As I say down south, you know the red dirt.
And the ambulance people helped me out a week, week, week.
So I go through this back door, which is a vestibule,
but it served as an intake room.
I knew something then was wrong.
So after the intake and all the paperwork, there's this vestibule.
And the vestibule leads to a horizontal perpendicular hallway.
Coming in, I go to the left.
There are patients in the hall on beds.
There are three rooms.
The first room in which I was placed had three beds.
The second huge room, I think might have had six to eight beds.
You cross that hall and there was a little black and white TV
that was smaller than the television that I ever had in any of my homes or boats.
And then across the hall was another huge room with about eight to ten patients.
You're describing the segregated black section of the room.
And that's the woman's side.
The bathroom was, let me if I can describe you,
you got the vestibule, then you come up to this horizontal hallway perpendicular.
And then after you pass that entrance to the hallway,
there is another hallway that continues vertically.
And it's massive.
At least it looks massive to me.
And glistening the floors.
And on that side, you had the kitchen.
And then you had the bathroom on the other side.
If I'm making sense across the hallway.
I did not know that men were on the other side of the hallway from the women's section.
So they placed me in the three-bedroom.
I guess that was for the elite.
And of course it was crowded.
And I guess for the first six months,
which shots every day, it's struck my son, and trying to get strength.
I didn't really pay any attention to the overall conditions,
except that I knew when I was able to get up and walk and go to the various huge wards,
I guess.
I was in the private room.
The two wards, I found it horrifying.
And we were clean up.
And I thought that was part of the therapy,
because I now know it's a lung problem, and I need to be strengthened.
And we were clean up our area, mop, and everything.
And I thought it was part of the therapy of strengthening oneself.
And so here it is now about June.
I'm strong, or.
And a little girl comes in with her mommy,
and they're in the ward, the big, the larger ward.
And I feel a responsibility to be her mentor.
I had learned how to crochet, and I had already known how to crochet,
but I crocheted so much.
I had it made lace, and you know, I was, you know, all of that.
Coming from my learning from my grandmother, on my mama's side, mommy.
So I asked to be moved to the larger ward,
so I could be with the little girl.
Her mama was very deathly ill.
Never, ever got from under the oxygen tent.
And I guess it's about August.
Well, before, no, it's August now.
Yes, August.
And there's the March on Washington.
And we sit on this little bitty, black and white TV.
And of course, at that time, the state,
Governor Wallace, I think, was governor.
And the state could just take away the television.
It was just going what we call it the blink.
But I saw another bit to discern that this was important.
This was about black people, it was about our rights, it was about freedom.
And then soon after that, in September, the four little girls in Birmingham.
And that came on, because we all watched the news, these hour in CIS,
because you had to fight about what we were going to look at.
A lot of them watched the little, when it searched for the moral,
whatever those little soapbox.
But the news came on at 6 o'clock, so there was not a conflict.
And I always wanted to watch the news.
And so I then learned, I saw my goodness.
Wow.
So then I took an extremely special interest.
And the little girl, she was nine years old.
And for the life of me, I cannot remember her name.
And by the way, we very seldom knew our last names.
And it was at that point that I said, look, the movement is wherever you are.
I have been taught that.
That the movement is not something that's imposed.
It's not an extracurricular activity.
It's wherever you are.
That's sanitarium.
Sanitarium became my movement base.
And I said, now we need to, meanwhile, they were bringing magazines to us on the card in that business.
And so my mind said, one of this place has a library.
And I asked, I say, is there a librarian here?
And they did, I think there was stunned.
And out of that, oh yes, I don't know what the motivation was.
And I said, it's probably up there, shiny hall.
And so one day I took the little girl by hand.
And I ventured.
And there were maintenance people, housekeeping people,
mopping and sweeping and taking care of them.
But we had to clean up our own.
There was a game room.
You know, it was, what do you call splendor?
There was a baby grand piano.
And what we would call a sitting room warplowler.
And I had taken music lessons all of my life.
And I went there.
And I sat down and I started playing, bomb, bomb, bomb, show pen, C sharp, pray,
Louder, C sharp, minor.
And you know, it has a real classic, classic kind of, dumb, dumb, and all.
And of course, the white people were just stunned, if not angry.
And across from the sitting room, there was a sitting room that was the front entrance.
And it's best to be able to, and then on the other side of that was the library.
And I went over there after, after white people started looking at me peculiar,
my little brain said, oh no, you're not going to do this.
Because there I have you up here like a toy.
And I'll become up here playing, you know, which made me fundamentally no different
than a manny.
I didn't care about a white child at the expense of my own.
So I said, but it stopped this.
So I go to the library and I pull out some books.
And then I politely walk back down the hall.
Nobody said anything to me.
The doctor was in and out, so he was like not a real participant.
And I guess this was a head nurse or whoever was in charge, but she was a woman.
And she came to talk to me quietly that I was not to do that.
So I go on up to the library, white woman, and all over a white star.
Kind of remind me later on the nurse that threw over the Cuckoo's Nest.
And I told her that I'm a college student, and this is a little girl.
And you all need to work out some kind of arrangement.
For me and this child to go to the library.
And I guess there was a human inkling in her.
And so she arranged, once Jim Crow terms, for me and the little girl to go to the library.
I can't remember what day's, but we would go and nobody would be in there but us.
And we could look and pull the books and maybe stay for about 30 minutes and read the books
because we couldn't bring them back.
We could bring magazines for not the books and sit up there and read the books.
I read their children's stories or whatever.
And so that was my first, not my first protest, but that was, and then secondly I got tired of the food.
They always gave us boiler food.
And what I mean by boiler food, greens, which were healthy, I'm not opposed to that.
But boiler food, potatoes, stew.
And I asked one day, I said, how come we eat all of this kind of food?
Don't y'all have some other kinds of food?
And whatever the whoever this nurse was.
She said, well, Gwen, you probably won't like this food.
That's what what is it?
She said, well, we're having oysters stew.
I said, mate, what cream or milk.
And she said, oh you, I see us, man.
I was polite.
I said, oh, I like to see the menu.
And I think we ought to have a chance to look at the menu and see what you're all serving, totally.
And put it on our little Bolton boy.
And after that, she didn't say anything, still.
And they didn't know what to do.
They were ready to hurry on and get me out of there.
And then I decided I'd go to the kitchen.
Because see, when you walked down the little colored section,
and to the main expanse of hallway, the kitchen was right there, not too far away.
And I went in the kitchen and looked.
And by that time, I guess I had a reputation because nobody had monitoring me,
nobody threatened me, nobody insulted me.
They were polite.
And I looked and looked and looked and saw what they saw, and then they started posting the menu.
So when they had perched fish as opposed to whitey, when they had big fish instead of fried fish,
I would choose, you know, other, and try to encourage my fellow patients to do likewise.
Now the other thing that was interesting about Benson Sanatorium,
they had a chapel, you know, a little prayer kind of room on the listening hallway.
We had to go outdoors.
And we would go outdoors and sit at this wooden table under a tree.
I think it was a pecan tree.
And that's where we had our services.
We never had a minister.
We would conduct our own services.
And the songs were always one I remember most.
Way over yonder where Jesus is.
I got a mother over yonder where I remember that of course my mother had passed.
And I learned a whole lot of new songs that we never signed in the Baptist churches here in Montgomery.
They were real, I used to call it, Dirtges of Christian music.
They were sad.
And they were always about death.
So it was at an impact on me.
Let me ask about all this.
Obviously we're polite.
And though youthful, a young adult obviously had an era of confidence and assertion about yourself.
Why do you think they tolerated you in those demands that you made?
Given what they might have said.
I think that they were impressed with my intelligence.
I think that they had made the assumption that black people were ignorant and stupid.
And when they could see that I would discuss with them.
I was determined.
I was not trying to raise them.
You were left there consciousness.
No, that was not.
You know, but I would say things.
Why is it important for you to keep black people and little children from learning?
And I think they had no answers or couldn't answer.
And they knew I was going to be temporary.
So they were really figuring out how to get me out of there.
And would tolerate me.
And I think to a certain extent respect me at the same time.
Because I made dollies and stuffed stuff.
Stuff, what do you call ducks?
I can't, you know, little stuffed animals.
And then my folks were sending me pajamas.
You say I also have that extended support base.
I'm sure they had read about me, my grandparents.
And all they knew also that if something happened to me wrong,
there will be at least some level of hell to play, or to pay.
And whenever they were visiting times, my folks came.
Tuskegee people came.
So I think it's that support base as well.
And I would make ducks and give them to them.
You know, the little head nurse who would come in all the time.
I gave her a little duck.
I used to make these hard crochet hearts.
You know, I knew out of stitch and double stitch and pick up stitch.
And then stuff, you know, get satin and then stuff with cotton.
And I would make little ones.
And I would give them to the doctors and people like that.
Thank you for that description.
And by the way, I was only going to want to call it a education.
Well, with some, because I had not graduated.
Sure, let's call it a campus.
That's lovely.
We're rolling again.
We're back after a short break.
Dr. Patton, let me ask you about arriving back on the Tuskegee campus in the fall of 64.
It's a campus now that SNCC folks are visiting everywhere.
Pick up the story with what you came back to.
Well, when I came back, I had a roommate.
Cannot think of her name.
But tuberculosis was considered like a plague.
And she did not want to be my roommate.
She was scared to death.
I was one big, fat disease.
And that bothered me to some extent.
But it didn't because the community among government
embraced me.
I got a job in the cleaners between, you know, Carvalesci.
And I had a sense of humor.
My folks loved me.
They will make it their business to drink a glass of water.
From my glass of water, you know, they didn't put any disinfectant in the water.
And so I had to go always have this background story.
So one day I met, I'm still wearing my...
I was saying with mommy, but I met my cousin, Flora, and Aunt Jix, the Lottie Dot Teachers.
And I'm eating there.
And I'm watching dishes.
And I poured some chlorox in the water.
And they said, when you don't have to do that, you know, being very, what do you call?
Someone paternalistic and caring and loving.
I said, yes, I do.
And they said, no, no, we love you.
That's okay.
I said, I don't need to catch a cold from one of y'all.
I might get to be again.
And they all laugh.
So I kind of, you know, so I was prepared.
But when this roommate acted such a fool and trying to make me into a big fat germ, I asked
for her to leave or to put me somewhere else.
And so the school I was in Travis Hall, which was the honor dorm.
So the school moved her.
So I was at my own room.
You see?
So I was really privileged.
Everybody else had a roommate, but me.
So when the SNCC people would come, the women, they could all stay in my room.
And they did.
And they all knew I'd had to be.
And they never made an issue out of it.
You know, whatever cake my grandma sent, they ate it.
And they did all for it.
But they bit it all.
So was that sisterhood that gave me even further strength from the greater community?
How did you make of these?
Let me ask.
What did you make of these SNCC women?
They were tough.
Committed.
Resolute.
But sometimes.
Sometimes.
I thought that sometimes I thought maybe I was too deep.
You know that maybe there was something wrong with the way I was thinking.
Because I was never for integration ever in my life.
What were your points then?
These segregation, equal opportunity, fairness, justice.
And see that goes all the way back to when I was in high school, I graduated from high school
in Montgomery.
And they wanted me to go to University of Alabama because I had the school authorities,
the principal, and my history teacher, my government teacher.
Because I had, because I was up, no, from up north.
But I'm in a black community up there.
But they don't see that.
They saw that I was from, even though they don't even know about Inxter, but Detroit.
So they made these assumptions.
And so they assumed that I would know how to interact with white people and not be frightened
or afraid of what I would not have been.
But I would see the sense of what going to University of Alabama for what?
How has University of Alabama distinguished itself?
You know all my life I've learned about George Washington, Carver, Booker T. Washington,
Yams (sweet potatoes) and peanuts, and peanuts, and science.
You know what?
So when they said, well, there's football and beer, Brian.
I said, oh, can I be a cheerleader?
And they just considered that frivolous.
And I wanted to be the world's best cheerleader.
I mean, that was like an avocation of mine before I was in this mysterious car accident.
So they said, don't be frivolous, Gwen, don't be silly.
So when they said that, I said, well, I'm not going up there.
So getting back, if I can make the story a whole, I was never for integration, for the sake of integration.
And then you have to also understand my upbringing.
You know, I didn't think I learned any better sitting next to a white child.
You know, that was not my paradigm.
I didn't define myself in juxtaposition to white people.
And that was reinforced with my grandmother, which goes all the way back to 56 on the bus boycott.
I mean, on the bus after the boycott.
And she always sat in the back.
And I will always sit up in the front and aggravate white folks.
They was an ensquirming and pushing and all, being a kid.
I'm 14, not back at the time, 15.
And one day there were no white folks in the bus.
So I went and sat in the back with mommy.
I said, we walked all these days, you walked.
And mommy and daddy sent money and shoes and did what I had to do.
And you still sit in the back.
I thought she was capitulating.
That she, I knew she was a block captain.
I knew she was in the movement.
I knew she thought voting was important.
But I still thought maybe you are afraid of white folks in a certain kind of way.
And she very lady like extremely lady like,
whoo, had far more class than my la la da teacher relatives.
And she always called me Gwendolyn, the whole name, not Gwen, but Gwendolyn.
Very proper.
And she said, Gwendolyn, the bus boycott was not about sitting next to white people.
It was about sitting anywhere you please.
And I am pleased to sit here.
And I had to sit back and take that in.
Which altered my whole thought process.
So when I meet SNCC people, all men and women in 64, this is before black power.
And they were about to sit here.
And they were about integrating and doesn't so.
I had a different kind of perspective.
But I knew these were some good people.
They were dedicated.
And maybe I need to look at my perspective as well to understand be self-critical.
But did not alter.
Because the more I saw, the more I said this is silly.
And it began with the desegregation of schools in Macon County.
And they were getting the middle class kids, the professional children,
to integrate the white school, which was downtown Tuskegee.
When the poor black and the poor working folks lived in downtown Tuskegee.
So they could have what, walking distances to the white folks homes,
to clean up, take you at a chilling, and those ones to be the yard man or the handy man.
So while we're going way over here in a bourgeois subdivision,
which is going to require busing, when we got black chillin right over here.
So that was my first, oh no, it ain't about integration.
You know, these folks.
And then at Tuskegee, you had the Negro swimming pool,
where the professional, and so, you know, chilling,
and the BA in Tuskegee Institute, chilling.
And I use that word purposely.
Swammed in the Negro pool, let's say on a Monday and the Wednesday.
And the poor and the working class Negro children swammed on the same pool on a two-cent Thursday.
So I saw right away the class problem in the cast.
And I had to just really struggle with this thing integration,
an integration for home.
And so I just had a different perspective.
Let me ask about some of these very thoughts that are right at the front of your mind,
I imagine, when you are sorting out what SNCC, the creation on campus of TIAL.
Right.
In early 65.
Yeah, I didn't believe in submerging.
And see, that goes all the way back.
Yeah, describe that didn't believe in submerging with a walk in your explainer.
You should not take the identity of a grassroots organization.
You should not subsune them.
As an organizer, you should do everything to lift them up so they can have their own identity,
their own structure, their own sense of how they are going to run that community organization.
Now that didn't come to me as a brilliant thought.
That came to me as a result of MIA.
When the Southern Christian Leadership Conference formed in 1957, at my church,
I talk southern touch with HHS, a HHS missionary Baptist Church.
And they wanted the MIA to become a chapter, an SCLC chapter,
and my grandparents and the folks whom I respected at work as a child and as a teenager said,
no, it was a Montgomery Improvement Association that spearheaded and directed and kept together
the 381 days we walked.
We are not going to give up that identity.
And to this very day, we have never had an SCLC chapter, but we still have MIA.
So I'm coming from that experience and bringing it to SNCC.
Now we have an organization.
It's called a Tuskegee Institute Advancement League, TIAL.
We were here before you got here.
We were involved in direct action, action, chair.
You know, we got a movement.
We're not only fighting the race question, we're fighting the class question within Black people,
which they had not a clue, because they subsumed all Black folks were alike.
And we saw the sharp distinctions.
Dr. Foster, who was President of Tuskegee, can I have him on a video by the way?
In the archives.
What have a Christmas party?
See, at Tuskegee was really a very bourgeois school.
We didn't watch.
We had a laundry on campus.
And they would come and collect our clothing and our linen and wash it and bring it back.
I mean, it was a very bourgy school as close to a prep school as you could get.
But Dr. Foster, the President, would have the laundry people, the maintenance people,
the help on the grounds, not the grounds superintendent.
He was in the bourgy class.
And one Christmas party, and then the professional and the VA people, had another Christmas party.
So when I became a student by the President, which I'm leaping,
I would always talk to him about cost effectiveness.
And that became a principle of mine as we interacted and we became very close.
I said, you know, it cost more money for you to have two distinct Christmas parties than if you had one.
And he being a businessman, you know, with a PhD, probably a master's in business.
And I don't know what his PhDs was at because I don't know if they had PhD in businesses at the time.
He could look at the bottom line.
And he began to reason with me.
And soon afterwards, we'd be almost became peers.
But I respected him as an authority.
And plus, he had impeccable grammar.
In fact, all of the black presidents, not all of them, many,
were sitting there, writing speeches to him, to prove read and edit and all that.
And I was impressed, you know, with his grammar.
There's so much activity on the campus in the fall of 64, in early 65.
But let me take the story to March, March 65.
Your election as president will follow,
but you are a very significant figure in organizing inside TIAL and campus figure.
Can you tell the story of those several weeks in March from Bloody Sunday through the Alabama State Capitol?
Well, you'll see the Alabama State Capitol a couple of times because...
Yeah, the March that didn't turn around.
Tuskegee had become a liberated zone.
I wish you knew how to get the old.
Snicks they were, they wanted to.
They went to classes.
They ate in the dining hall.
You know, the whole nine yards.
So that is to say that the administration had given up and had to...
Totally given up.
And we had faculty support.
Gene Wiley, Maggie McGee, Dean Wassertrom.
It was a very complex situation because Dr. Foster had hired all of these white people
who were progressive, which always fascinated me because most white people who come to black college campuses are progressives.
You know, and Gene Wiley was black.
And so they displace the black professionals.
I never forget the slide of meeting, little on as when I was doing my president.
A black and white professor is getting together to see if we can work this thing through.
Because the black professors were becoming nationalist.
You know, and the white professors were our buddies.
So anyway, that is another story.
But prior to the march from Selma to Montgomery.
SNCC, as I said, was everywhere on campus.
And had freedom.
And Dr. Foster really not knowing what to do.
And Tuskegee being a quasi-private and public institution.
The state had no authority.
You know, Governor Wallace and the state apparatus.
So students would go to Lowndes County, go to Dallas County, you know, and help organize.
And that made sense to us because we were now toying with the whole concept that education has to be relevant.
And if you're not serving the community, then what good does it mean for you to get a degree?
And so we were win those arguments intellectually.
And we played excellent chess.
I was a real excellent bridge player.
You know, so it was all of that if you can see the complexity of what we were becoming.
Plus our professors had us read.
They took Phil.
When you read that, I mean, I was supposed to come out of that.
You know, and then we had Negro history was compulsory.
You know, so when you read W.E.B. Du Bois, whatever his limitations, or Book of Tea, whatever his limit,
how do you suppose to come out of that?
I mean, I thought education was to inform you and change your behavior.
And so it changed our behavior to be more revolutionary.
You know, I dealt with the whole question of homosexuality.
In fact, my sophomore paper was on homosexuality.
I want to look that up in the card catalog at the time.
And I always said, deviant behavior.
And I had a cousin, Bobby, who lived with me while I was in Inkster, at Wayne State University Library Science,
who was in love with a neighborhood family, a friend, that my brother and I knew was Sissy.
Because that's what we called him, a Sissy.
His name was Junior's name was Robert Harris.
They both died so I can call him name.
And we love Junior. We call him Junior.
And we loved him.
But we could not understand what Bobby didn't see.
That he was a Sissy. We didn't know Gaye was not a term.
And anyhow, she got pregnant.
So we said, well, maybe he ain't.
Right? You know.
And they had a son.
And they got married.
So I'm still close to Junior.
And he looked at me and said, one day, are you homosexual?
And he looked at me and he admitted it.
So that's why I want to write a paper on this.
I said, because when I look in the card catalog, all I see is deviant behavior.
And you ain't deviant to me.
You're a lot of fun.
I love you.
You know, so tell me.
That's what he told me about the Mattachine Press and San Francisco.
That's what he told me about a book.
I think with Twilight, I can't recall.
It was almost like a Bible to the gay world, male gay.
Twilight or something.
It has something to do with stars.
And he told me what to read and Mattachine Press and San Francisco and all of that business.
So I'm open to that now.
I'm not quite open up to Lesbian just yet,
and we call them Dykes then, Bull Divers or Dykes.
But I was open up to homosexuality.
And that's what I learned when I read about it.
That's what I learned about Lesbos.
I never forget that.
And then I learned the clinical term.
If you will, I should use the word clinical.
I should use that term at all.
Lesbos, Lesbian.
So I began to lose people through that.
So I don't know how I got to this, but coming to SNCC.
I don't know if there were so much in the heat of the day
that they didn't do a lot of thinking or contemplation like I did.
And maybe others, that they were quite there.
Okay, that's back to the record.
I'm sorry, I have to be careful.
I say this.
So in TIAL, we had these kinds of discussions
about people, personalities, identities, lifestyle.
George Ware, who was from Buffalo, New York.
George Davis, Rhode Island.
Sammy Younge Jr, who had gone to school, up in New Hampshire and over.
No, he didn't go to the end of it.
We went to one of those prep schools.
These are enrolled students at Tuskegee Bridge.
Yeah, enrolled.
My classmates, my peers.
The girls were Ruby Taylor, who was basically,
she was from the Black Belt here in Alabama, Pickens.
County.
Other girls, Kathleen Neal Cleaver, was in and out.
She had been to a prep school.
In other words, there was a broader, what do you call, perspective.
And different levels on the spectrum of understanding.
And we could have those discussions within TIAL.
Snip was so caught up in the heat of the day
that we very seldom had philosophical discussions at that time.
We're talking.
You're much more tactical.
How to deal with SLC.
You know, you're serving grassroots organizing, day in, day out, drudgery.
You come home, you're tired.
You've been beaten by a clubster or a sympathizer.
And so you didn't have that luxury.
Even though SNCC did do a great deal of talking,
or as we would say, great deal of talking.
But it was all about, who are you?
Where do you come from?
And I don't know what that was about.
It was an integrated group.
It sounds like you're just about to crystallize that notion of the scholar activist.
Oh yeah, we had done that.
You know, you couldn't be dumb.
You know, you simply could not be dumb.
You cannot be in the struggle in the movement.
If you were not doing well in school, the movement could not have
been insolent.
I had to use the word dumb, but that's, you know, the vernacular.
But undisciplined, unaware kinds of people.
Didn't you have to once on that point answer, was it Stokely Carmichael?
Who put that question to you?
Is your education really valuable?
Oh yes.
Stokely, Stokely really tried to get all, because he was impressed with Tuskegee kids.
Plus we had also told the administration, this is what we're going to do.
You know, we are freedom fighters.
This institution has prepared us to be freedom fighters.
I mean, we were just not in arrogant terms, but in rational terms.
You know, what do you expect?
And Stokely was impressed with that.
I'm sure they had that at Howard.
And it looked like they could have had that at Howard even better,
because they had a president who was already, they're a good march on all of that.
And perhaps they were intellects, but they dealt with it as an elitism thing.
I know what Stokely [Carmichael] and [Mike] Thelwell and all of them were coming from.
So, and they had also, Stoke people and Stoke men in particular,
had almost the same kind of attitude towards Southern blacks
as a variation of how those white folks saw me at Benson Sanatorium.
We were Southern, we were supposed to be country dance stereotypes, stereotypes,
not to be deep thinkers, let alone make analysis.
And I think that kind of set them back.
And Stokely wanted everybody to drop out and join SNCC.
And I confronted him, I say, you went back to Howard and got your degree.
How dare you do that?
Because also I saw a practical side.
We needed the same reason that I had to tell Bettina Aptheker.
When she came down back in some years, I guess I was in 66,
prior to my break in my leg.
And she was astonished that we had an ROTC and we weren't picketing.
And I said, oh no, no, no, Bettina.
And I became very close and to her father and her mother.
I say these kids go to school.
Oh, I know it was. Bettina had come down and we had this grand parade of all these ROTC folk.
And General Chappy James was leading,
or General Benjamin O'Davis, because they both were Tuskegee Airmen and Tuskegee Grat.
And Bettina was horrified.
And I said, no, no, no, Bettina.
I said, a lot of these students here need ROTC to get scholarships.
It's just that simple.
So it was a practical thing that Tuskegee kids had,
as well as a philosophical underpinning.
And I don't think, stick people understood that very well,
nor did, and antiwar people later.
Because we had one of the best draft counseling centers.
You know, we knew how to do CO, conscientious objectors.
What are we going to get to that?
Okay. But getting back to Stokeley, Stokeley could not argue.
Even let me take you back.
Just for a calm new tongue, because I know that we're pressing against your day
and when you need to leave this interview.
So let me have you talk about that March of 65.
From Bloody Sunday through you will go ultimately,
you'll go on Wednesday from buses from Tuskegee to Montgomery.
And then you will go and make the March also.
Yes.
So tell me about that.
Okay.
We're organizing for the March what's Nick people in Dallas County so forth.
I'm in meetings as direct action chair of TIAL,
with James Forman and others, Hosea Williams Williams, Dr. King and all,
and Birmingham at A.G. Gaston Motel.
And it was decided that we were going to leave kick off that Sunday.
And we were going to march till we got to Montgomery.
We thought it was going to be three days.
You know, we had no idea.
And that had been decided democratically.
So even though we were philosophical, we were practical,
we're also idealistic.
This is what we had decided.
So we come back to Tuskegee and we're going to organize the East Black Belt.
East Black Belt.
Okay.
Not only Tuskegee, Macon County, but also Bullock County,
which included Union Springs, which is a Black Belt County.
And so Sammy takes the lead in that same young raising money and
stopping cars on what we call campus avenue, the main thoroughfare,
and to stop like collecting buckets of money,
ordering, see we were also very organized.
We were far more organized and SNCC by the way, in terms of logistics.
I was so concerned about the scholar activist concept that you could not cut classes
and go on a demonstration.
So we had to figure out who had cars, who had many cars,
but we had to figure that out and do a grid, you know, on matrix,
or whatever you would do.
And you would go and pick it downtown at the supermarket or the registrar's office.
We had transplanted every hour on the hour, so you would not miss a class.
SNCC was just, I mean, just like, what do you call startled, if you will.
But James Forman who is an organizer and a tactician, marveled at it.
And so he really became the mentor for tidal kids on campus.
So he was stokily soon left and went to Lowndes County,
because he can deal with the rule.
You understand the stereotype fit.
Oh, I don't know if I want this on the record or not.
But that's an assumption on my part.
And they were practical people, deep common sense, you know, self-taught,
were philosophical still are.
And their way of being philosophical, then we studied at.
I mean, they were going to go in deep thought.
They got all of the possibilities, you know, the obstacles and so forth.
And I think people will mantisize that.
But anyhow, form and became the key person at Tuskegee,
and stokily became the key person in Lowndes County,
for whatever reasons.
So blood is Sunday happened.
And we see it on television in the door,
because we were not there then.
And we were horrified like the rest of the nation and the world.
So we really, we really, we really, we got a really gear up,
get our stuff organized, organize the community, get cars.
You know, we go on the Montgomery, we go meet them.
And that, because we thought it was going to be Wednesday.
You have to remember three days we thought it take, three or four days.
And that Tuesday, I think it was Dr. King,
Nellte, prayed and turned around.
Unprincipled, it had been agreed upon by the collective
that we were going to do this march.
Nyee, youngsters, how could he do that?
He promised, I mean, we almost went into infantile, you know, behavior.
He promised, Nellte children, but you promised, how can you break your promise?
I mean, we were, then we became fortified.
But you were ranked.
Oh, I was mad as hell.
That night, Judge Frank M. Johnson Jr, they just put a big thing up there.
And I give him credit because he did a lot of things subsequently, you know,
around mental health and jail and so forth.
His pen was a mighty sword.
Issued this injunction.
I was too angry.
And Dr. Foster, and I'm still being called in,
oh, we had deposed the student body president because he was from New York
and he was not a part of the movement and would not put the student government
at the disposal of the movement.
So George Ware, from Buffalo, and this other guy was from New York City,
deposed him and George Ware assumed,
the student government, but he had no power because he couldn't deal with the money or anything,
right? But he used to be at a space.
And George was in graduate school.
Chemistry, brilliant, brilliant, still is brilliant.
But Dr. Foster shows the deal with me,
a woman, had TV, or whatever his thing, he thought I was a little bit more malleable.
Not knowing where I was coming from.
And so he called me in.
I'm direct action of TIAL too.
So I gave him the hook and he said,
when you cannot march, there is an injunction.
We said, what is that? Peace paper.
We showed it to him, and I looked at him, I looked at him, I saw.
Okay.
And he had copies made and put it in the dining hall on the chairs.
But we had already organized this caravan and the buses.
So I paid him no amount, no attention.
Nor that piece of it, I didn't read the piece of it, but George Ware read the paper.
So we could own up and we tell him, we tell him, we're going.
Either you come and go with us, we had organized the cafeteria workers.
And I'm sure Dr. Foster has something to do with that.
But we had organized them, if he had not agreed, there would have been a little strike by them.
And my buses came, we paid for them.
The cars, the community was organized.
Must have had about 30 or 40 cars in the caravan.
Because we believe in organizing totally.
That was my whole thing.
Because I come from the Montgomery bus boycott.
You got to have the word at that time was a base.
And the cafeteria folks fixed this little baloney sandwiches and an apple and a little paper thing
of juice and so forth.
And we come on down in Montgomery.
So when say the 10th?
When say the 10th, James Forman's book, Quanticals It, very, very well.
And so here we are in Montgomery.
George had read where?
And perhaps George Davis too, had read the injunction very well.
And it said nothing about a march coming from Macon County to Montgomery.
It was only injunction from Selma to Montgomery.
So they were able to play the legal.
Meanwhile, of course they put us in jail.
You know, Dr. King and them are furious with us.
And this Montgomery community turned on us, the boogeys, and Dexter Avenue Baptist Church.
That's a whole nother story.
They never had a mass meeting at Dexter Avenue Baptist Church.
And I can tell you a whole story between Dexter Avenue Baptist Church and First Baptist Church,
who kept out night in 1961 with the freed riders,
and how those two churches split.
Dexter Avenue Baptist Church was an offshoot of First Baptist Church, a very lovely beautiful church,
or Nate, pipe organ, terracotta, sealings, you know,
stained glass windows, the preacher there who did all of that was called Reverend Stokes.
He was a more attrition, but he was a race man.
And if you go there to this day, he put those things,
windows up the pews from Italy, the whole nine, the pulpit.
And if you look at the window, one of the things huge,
there is John the Baptist, baptizing Jesus, right?
And above that pain is Reverend Stokes.
Okay?
You can tell me about a race man.
And so I have all these great stories.
And when you go in there, the church, by the way,
the architect was from Tuskegee.
The ceiling, the attic, is eight feet in depth.
So down the road, a piece in which my grandfather built one little town,
was called Newtown.
Initially, was all plantation.
And so all of the folks that are down the hill,
what they call North Montgomery, Powertown, Newtown,
and my grandfather had to build a lot of those long shotgun houses.
We'll come up to the church with their overalls and whatever.
And then you get a few little doctors, well, not too many doctors.
No lawyers, but you get a lot of those school teachers.
And they don't want to be bothered with those spill hands.
So they get angry and go to Texas, which is down the town.
And right up the street, all of this expectation,
this status foolishness.
And for years, families, what do you call?
When you have family feuds, family split, you know,
based on superficial class stuff.
And it was only until Dr. King, who became pastor at Dexter Avenue Baptist Church,
and they did not support nothing, absolutely nothing.
The high pollutants became dear friends to Rev. Ralph Abernathy,
who talks with a big poem, well, from Black Belt.
I think he was from Marion, Alabama, Perry County, Alabama.
They became close, then the churches became close,
and then families became close.
That's the story behind Dexter Avenue Baptist Church.
So here we are on a march, coal, rainy, drizzling night.
And we take refuge.
Because you asked the same governor, he refuses.
Oh, he puts George Davis, none of them in jail.
Yeah, and I've got to say a couple of things here.
Tell us, we'll count for this tape.
How many people you mobilize from the campus?
I think we had 2,300 students at the time that I remember, about 1,500.
About 1,500, one of them.
Yeah, it's a story.
So three of them.
All we had to do, we had an organist that organized.
We were being in Donning Hall, and we were beginning to stop our feet on the floor.
And that meant we had to all go to the valley,
because we about to have a mass meeting.
You know, and everything was done democratically.
We had to vote on everything.
You know, all of that, we were not involved in iconic leadership.
There was no thing around women that I knew about at the time.
It was all about if you had skills, the analysis.
If you could persuade, you know, not so much persuasion,
but persuasion by reason.
You know, then you became a leader.
So for some reason the church is open.
I don't know who were locking churches or not at that time.
Or somebody broke it, I don't know.
But when are you in Dexter Avenue Baptist Church?
As a refugee.
Yeah, it was called, it was drizzled.
We had no bathroom, you know, the forming does the great pee in.
And all of these little silly tactics.
That's a state troopers would do.
And then the city police and the county,
and you know, they plan all silly games.
And we about time and time to fool around
with all of their little foolishness,
the authorities foolishness.
So we go to Dexter Avenue Baptist Church, Dr. King Church.
And we're in there, and we wake up,
sleep anywhere on the floor on the fuse.
The water, the toys won't flush.
It's colder in there than it was outside.
They got the heat off.
You know, the lights wouldn't cut on.
It was awful.
Then we decided, well, we're going to take over this.
And you have to tell me,
how it was those things cut off.
The Deacons did it.
I even now won't call names,
because they have, what do you call?
Going through absolution.
You know, you're redeeming themselves.
So there's no need for names.
But I was furious.
So I said, leave in the church.
We're going to stay there.
Because the cops were outside the church.
And that's when Alabama State students came.
And served as a buffer.
But we still do, after we came outside,
we still held the church.
Because we had big meetings down there.
And there was this big meeting discussion
between George Ware and Forman.
And George, he was older, he was a grad student.
And George, I think,
was looking out for the protection of the students.
So he got into
a whole state of mind as an adult.
And Forman had manipulated us children.
And here we are.
You know, stuck can't get back to Tuskegee.
It's cold.
They're in jail.
So George became protective, paternalistic.
And Forment as an adult over these little undergrads.
And Forman was a manipulator.
Well, I didn't see it that way at all.
So I took issue with George Ware.
You know, I said, no, we are grown.
We knew precisely what we were doing.
We knew the risks, you know.
And I think that was part of how I got elected student body president.
You know, how dare you be content in me?
We're not sheep, we're scholars.
And this is what we wanted to do.
Nobody was killed.
So that was a turning point.
And we call that the the the march that wouldn't turn around.
And some kids have researched the archives in my papers
and have one state history awards.
One kid in particular in New Mexico, his mama,
his grandmother lives here.
And he's a military kid.
And he knew a Tuskegee suit.
Because we had organized the ROTC.
And doing my administration, they were my personal bodyguards.
Okay.
You know, and where was munitions chat?
Oh yeah, we knew all of that.
Particularly, we knew where I was coming from.
Or where Tuskegee kids were coming from.
So this young kid, and I read his paper,
The State Archives, as a presentation,
his father, New Tuskegee grad, ROTC grad.
And he told him about the the the march that wouldn't turn around.
I never used that name.
That name came from this youngster.
Let me ask about your, actually, John, let's call us for that.
Okay, we're going to get to the short break.
Okay.
The the the march that wouldn't turn around.
Because we had said it was to be a march.
And Tuskegee students, led by Sammy Younge Jr,
was one of the grade organizers, but it was a whole committee.
Oh, buses and cars to be true to what we had said.
It was a relay march.
People in cars would get out,
like in the middle of the caravan,
would get out and walk.
And then the cars behind would come up, pick them up,
students would get out.
And then the youngster literally held to our word
that it was a march.
And then the youngster,
dubbed it or entitled it,
the the the march that wouldn't turn around.
Okay, let's take a short break.
Okay.
Okay, we're back after a break about five or ten minutes
and we'll do a last segment here to finish up.
Dr. Patton, thanks so much for your patience in hanging in there with us.
I know it's a lot of hard work in your chair.
It's not close to me.
Sorry?
But I think a male carrier just came to the front door.
That was the noise we did.
If you could talk a little bit about,
think about the period from spring 65 forward,
especially after 66, I guess,
the changes that will quickly kind of reshape,
snow.
And how you continue to push your thinking about the question
of social change, race,
and you ask it.
Oh, that's a tall order.
I'll try to be brief.
If you look at eyes on the prize
and it recaptures the Selma to Montgomery March,
you will see in Lowndes County,
which was the longest stretch
and has been the most overlooked,
is Selma to Montgomery,
when it ought to be Selma to Lowndes to Montgomery.
And I've always resonated with grassroots people.
And as you look at that,
you see a lot of people on the side.
Those were Lowndes County people.
And some SNCC people.
I was on the march initially.
Being an organizer,
and perhaps a tacticianer,
my greatest concern was how were the people
going to eat?
How were they going to go to the bathroom?
So my little brain told me,
about Tuskegee Feeds,
2300 students every day.
Surely they ought to be able to prepare meals for the marchers.
And so I wouldn't talk to Dr. Foster about that,
the president,
and though we could not budget much money,
and I had been on the march and saw the food,
stayed overnight one night in one of the campsites.
Lynn Chandler was there.
I remember him so well.
And I said, I can't take this food anymore.
So I guess my sensibilities of how I was raised
as a black, middle, solid, middle class,
and then the black cast,
probably upper middle class.
So my sensibility,
and I was taught not to make distinction among people.
Are a product of their circumstances.
And that's a whole nother philosophical influence
that my father,
as well as my extended family,
instilled in me,
not to make a difference.
But I was tired of that food,
and Tuskegee did provide a meal.
I never forget it.
A barbecue chicken.
I was so pleased that Dr. Foster,
because I began to really feel now that he really understood
the depth of what we were trying to do.
And it was really a positive reflection
of how we had been taught.
What our purpose was,
how mission,
the Christian ethic to care for the least of these Matthew 25.
So anyway, I just had to bring that in
because that's still very pointing in my mind.
And we didn't eat the stewed like the boil of food
that I had seen in Benson Sanatorium.
So the mark is over.
The Lounge County has a rich, rich movement history
from slavery times to reconstruction all the way up.
And there were a proud people still are.
And I thought they were being cheapened,
not fully understood,
and I respected for their deep, deep wisdom.
So we're having these great discussions
with the TIAL at Tuskegee.
And SNCC people and gem form in particular.
We finally had come to the,
to the, I don't, it's not a conclusion,
but to the point that there is a fundamental distinction
between integration and desegregation.
And then desegregation led to self-determination.
We were there.
And the Lowndes County people,
we got the voting rights act, right?
We got the power of the vote.
Now what do we do with this vote?
And the Lowndes County people made a very clear, John Hulett.
Oh bless our heart as much as I loved her, loved her.
And stay there at home.
She ran for school board.
She was a school teacher.
It occurred to me.
I have it in there, our cops back there.
They said they didn't want to be mayor,
or run for even city council.
Because we didn't even know what a city was.
We didn't deal with city government.
We dealt with county government.
They weren't interested in being state representatives.
They were interested in being holding those positions,
which were the closest to the people,
foremost being the high share,
you know, who would just come,
unclove, unrobed,
and the black community.
They wanted the Board of Education,
so their children can have a decent quality education,
which had nothing to do with Bunsen burners,
even though we needed them.
But quality, teaching,
they wanted to be tax assessors,
because those black farmers who did have land
were always assessed tremendously,
while the white areas of the white plantations
were almost taxed kneel.
And then the collectors,
the corner, where black people will be found dead in jail,
on the roadside, or in ditches.
And the corner will come and say it was suicide,
or self-inflicted.
So that made a lot of us think,
again, about what is the significance of the vote?
And that was to elect people,
closest to the people.
They wanted their own political party.
There were efforts by Robert Kennedy,
a journal general at the time,
to have the new black vote voted into the Democratic Party.
And again, they dealt on a national level,
on what we call a, you know, out barf-betched,
our vicinity, our assets,
the people who are closest to the people.
We weren't interested.
We didn't even know what a damn delegate was.
Now, of course, we knew about the Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party,
Fannie Lou Hamer,
and we made it very clear to SNCC,
that we were not going to replicate that model.
So, last time we got some votes on board.
We looked at it,
it wasn't in competition.
We just felt going to Atlantic City,
some far distant place might as well go to Mars,
from hour,
range of experiences.
We weren't interested in electing delegates.
We were interested in electing the sheriff.
I have to ask you,
in that next election,
you think the election is stolen?
Can you talk a little bit about that?
Yeah, I wrote about that.
It was stolen.
Yeah, it was there.
There were still black people in Lowndes County.
We were naive.
We thought the vote was some modicum of freedom,
and that we could vote to be a free voter.
But we saw the white terror,
the surface with behemoths,
people who were tenant farmers,
who had to have a relationship
with the owners of the plantation.
We still call it a plantation.
We're in a very dangerous position,
and the landowner, the white plantation man,
built hand, system, and farmers to the polls.
Tell them how the reprisals were just enormous.
And people who have nothing,
the reprisal was that,
because they couldn't take anything.
We didn't have anything,
so look at they take, but our lives.
But the people press were bearded.
They voted.
I wrote a piece called No Clouds in the Sky,
where the plantation owner,
property owner, white property owner,
voted for everybody who worked on his property,
in his fields.
That was a lot.
There was gun violence.
I just have to give you my paper,
which also has the voting tallies.
You did in that same November 65 election.
No, this is November 66.
The Voting Rights Act was passed in August.
We began to organize in Lowndes County.
I'm not sure if you're exactly right.
You do, however, in part because of all the work
that's been done in making county,
do you elect a black sheriff in making county?
Yes.
At the consternation of the black middle class bourgeoisie,
he was dog skin in you.
Lucius Amerson, there was a book written by his son.
I think I have the book back here for you to take notes
so you can follow up on it.
Yes.
Let me ask you a final question.
I know we really kept you at long time.
What I asked for in a key final question.
The car accident in 67 is very unusual.
The circumstances are very unusual.
Still don't know.
I can even get a police report.
If you were, just copy the basics of that episode.
Well, it was the eve of the first black power conference,
which was underwritten by Sharp,
with SNCC people being the facilitators.
This is going to happen at Tuskegee.
At Tuskegee.
You have to read James Forman's book because it didn't take place
on Tuskegee campus.
It was supposed to, and I had organized that.
I was at part of where we were to meet in the rooms the night before.
Dr. Foster somehow canceled that.
But Dean Phillips, Dean of Students,
when we had called to bait it, was a part of us now.
He was supportive of what we were doing.
He arranged something at the Boy Scouts camp for somewhere.
Meanwhile, I'm in this car accident.
I'm taking a young man to my grandmother's home, my momy,
to lay over because I had a range for him to fly to Canada to avoid the drive.
And we're in this mysterious car accident.
We don't hit anything, nothing hits us.
I don't know how it happened.
And it happened, and evidently I blacked out because I don't remember anything
until I woke up at John Andrew Memorial Hospital on the campus.
James Forman, all of the SNCC people were there.
We got a new crop of Tuskegee people now.
I had graduated.
And they elected me, by the way.
I was in graduate school at Tuskegee the summer of 1966 before I went to Sharp
as vice president.
They wanted to re-elect me as president, but I had graduated.
And there was something about the student body president had to be a senior.
But again, George Ware, Sharp with the legalese,
said nothing about the qualifications of the vice president.
So I ran his vice president and won.
And my main thing then was that we got to line up presidents for the next four years,
which we did, Warren Hamilton and Benny James and, you know, at all.
You know, to keep this movement thing alive, that's how I think, I think, like that.
And so that night, February the 10th, 1967, I never forget it.
I'm in the Strumina's car accident.
I'm in John Andrews hospital.
So I met another, a, we call obstacle in my life.
And I have to have blood transfusions and SNCC people and students.
That's when I wrote the piece on Book Day Washington.
About the accident, your sense of, you have a such an odd thing, a part of your car failed, didn't it?
Yeah, the whole, what you call axelot, broken ass.
So you wonder if someone temporary could call it.
I try not to even think about it.
But it has to be, I mean, how can an axelot isn't that the kind of like the skeleton,
how does it crack and how?
But what's significant about that, and then we're going to conclude,
is that I'm in the hospital, Dr. Hume, who's a bourgeois doctor,
who never supported movement activities, really thought we were destroying the,
what they thought, the model city, that was the little thing that,
that's why we try to integrate the churches, the poor.
Now, why are you crazy?
Is white folks don't like you?
Okay, and that's another whole story.
And so Dr. Hume hated us, the movement, me in particular,
a student body president, wanted to cut my leg off, amputate.
And what kicked in, to be honest, was Freud.
My whole thought process, I'm 22 years old.
And my thing was, what if a man and I are intimate, you know,
and some kind of, what do you call, pre, you know,
and we're kind of taking off our clothes, sexily,
and then I said, oh, wait a minute, I got to take off my leg.
That was my motivation, I'm telling you, that's honest.
And so I called my paternal grandparents.
No, I asked Dr. Hume to show you another stream of thought
that shaped my consciousness.
And I said, have you talked to another doctor about this?
You know, have you had second opinion?
And he was, uh, caustic, he says,
that's what's wrong with him, you think you know everything?
And then I leaned over, I said, have you talked to the Lord about it?
It was the Lord.
He said, well, what does God have to do with it?
So I leaned back, I said, put the priest paper on the nightstand.
I called my grandparents, my paternal grandparents, my granddaddy,
he's straight as an arrow, deacon trusty, emeritus,
never smoke, never drink, or some of his goose who pretended for life,
you know, read the Bible, taught me the Bible, you know,
and all of the precepts and all of that.
And I told my, I said, my dear, this man said that he didn't need to talk to the Lord about my foot,
come and get me.
My grandmother and granddaddy dispatched my cousin,
and they came and got me, because this man was a heather.
And that's how I got out of the hospital.
I think if I never said that, then they would have sided with the doctor,
because he knows best.
My little brain just, as always,
but when he couldn't understand that the Lord had everything to do with it,
and then when I got back home, I went to stay with my mommy,
my maternal grandmother,
because I just found so much comfort with her.
That's when I called a patina at that girl.
All of my ducks in the row.
That began your transition to New York?
That I told patina, I got to find my doctor.
What about the medical committee for human rights?
Medical committee, yeah.
Let's use that.
Let's use that point as our stopping point today.
You've been so generous and just such an honor and privilege to be with you.
Thank you so much.
But let me, because you, thank you so much,
but I want to be fair to SNCC.
And so it's when I'm in New York,
it's the SNCC people, and particularly James Forman,
the core people who had a relationship with SNCC people.
And then I also, my fiance was in New York,
who really came to support me.
Which is right to do.
I became a call celebrate.
Julia Wright, which is right to do it.
We'll come and see when she came from Paris.
And all patina attacker, the Communist Party,
the Social Workers Party, the Progressive Labor Party.
And I was introduced to all of these new people, Mary Kochiyama.
I never seen a Japanese person in my life.
His spat, and I shouldn't say that.
Latinas, Latinos, Puerto Ricans.
I never saw a Spanish person in my life.
So my world was just really open even more.
And so when I got out of the hospital,
or on those furloughs from the hospital,
because I would be in there for six months at a time,
organized a union, $199, I know it.
Play poker and won all of the money.
And I was a good poker player.
And all of that, that when I got out,
that's when I said I will work for SNCC.
And I did.
Thank you so much for what a wonderful visit.
From the Library of Congress,
and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.